你还在被AI绘图工具跟前
因为限制问题被搞得崩溃
浮水印
低化质
收费昂贵
还得绑定账号
这些问题今天全部解决
今天将带你解锁完全免费的AI绘图神器
Rafael AI
无浮水印
无限制
不需注册
甚至没假设可生成200缸高清图
我们将实测这款工具的核心功能
看它到底是不是如传说中那么强大
还在被坑的你
点好订阅收藏带赶紧跟我一起上车
我没上车
乍看之下
Rafael AI似乎只是
众多AI图片生成工具中的一款
但他直接打出免费无限免登入的旗号
这究竟是黑科技还是另有引擎
我们马上来验证
看到第一排我就绷不住了
不是说好的免费吗
这个定价按钮是什么鬼啊
抱着怀疑的态度我点击去看了看
发现他给出的解释是
订阅我速度会更快
订阅我你就没有广告
订阅我你就没水印
好家伙这算是把友商那套玩得明明白白友商是啥这里有个说明使用英文输入提示词已获得最佳效果我就用中文写了一个简单的提示词
看看会怎么样
可以看到基于flux模型生成出来的图片
还是稳如老狗
可就在我不小心滑动了一下鼠标的时候
我刚才生成的图呢
我翻遍了网站所有能点的地方
也没有找到类似个人存储空间的地方
可以看到他一次生成了
四种不同风格的图片
眼开放大
我发现清晰度一般般
嘿
还不是因为没有充值
不过他很贴心的
为大家准备了一个精修功能
我们来看看效果
都可以看到对比起来
不管是精细度还是清晰度
都有一定的改善
区别还是有的
要是你觉得这张图
你还比较满意的话
请你一定及时下载
保存起来
体现难度
现在我给他一个复杂的提示词
然后所有设定都默认的情况下
看看会生成什么样的结果
可以看到这四张图片
显然和我所提供的提示词
还存在一定差距的
也只有第四张图相对比较接近一点
这让我不禁想起
使用英文输入提示词以获得最佳效果说干就干同样的提示词我把它翻译成英文粘贴上去所有设定也是一样点击生成前两张还是挺接近的第三张就差点意思了
不对
还有一张没生成出来
我们等等看
如果同一个提示词
我们多生成几次
看看有没有能达到
我们预期效果的
哦
看我看到了什么宝子们
通过三次的抽卡
终于得到了一个
比较符合提示词的图片了
而且色调细节构图都相当灵活
我们写上一个提示词
在下方猜数这里
选择一个竖屏的比例
风格选择一个电影风格
再选一个冷色调
最后选择一下光线和构图
OK点击生成
咦你别说你还真别说
经过一番调教以后
出来的效果还是挺不错的
基本都在点子上了
我把提示词给大家翻译过来
大家自己看看效果如何
就还好
如果你对这效果还是不满意
你可以用它的图片参考功能
我们现在上传一张参考图
Rafael AI会根据这张图的风格来生成新图片
你可以在图片下方用滑块调整参考图的影响强度它默认是20%点不管了 先拉到100然后再写上提示词在下方选择一个和参考图相同的图片比例然后点击生成
不出意外
这个美女将在20秒后被鲨鱼咬4次
果然不出我所料
完美
这谁都能知道好吧
我也分别将参考比例设置为50%
20%
以及10%
我缺点总结
优势当然就是免费啦
无限制啦
不用担心额度问题
整合了一个升级解析度的功能
还是比较良心
那缺点也是比较明显的
每次生成都要输入验证码
还是很讨厌
图片不会自动保存
刷新页面就会丢失
既然可以选择登录
就不能做个个人图像机这种东西
总之做一个无限制使用的
AI生图工具来用
还是挺赚的
速度也过得去交伙伴
如果不介意那些缺点的话
就赶快去尝试一下吧
好啦记得订阅我的频道
我会持续带来最新最实用的AI工具评测
按赞这支影片
并留言告诉我们你最想测试的AI工具
我们下支影片见咯
拜拜